at saturday's republican presidential
debate in Manchester New Hampshire
demonstrators were kept in a free speech
zone a mile from the media assembled at
the venue reasontv spoke with some of
these politically active citizens about
who they are supporting for president we
also caught up with vermin supreme a
performance artist an occasional
presidential candidate so what's your
biggest issue in the campaign well of
course in America today I believe
there's a serious lack of ponies in
everybody's life and that is why I'm the
only candidate promising each every
American their very own pony that's
right it's a job at creation program so
why Cruz Cruz the strong constitutional
conservative he's going to try to make
gains for the conservative movement
rather than stagnation because Cruz is
the strongest constitutional
conservative this country's seen in a
long time that's why so why Trump I'm
picket sign have a businessman the White
House to be running the country I think
the government should run like a
business I think there is too much with
too much jet our veterans aren't taken
care of and we'd have more jobs
available the cockpit he's when he's
when he talked about banning all Muslims
for a certain amount of time until the
war on terror is one what do you think
about that I don't think he plans on
banning him until the war on terror is
done but he wants to do is look at a
real solution a real solution to figure
out how to make sure to keep our country
safe the number one job of any commander
in chief is to keep the country safe
that is number one so with Rand Paul out
of the race Ted Cruz said he's going to
be trying to you know grab the Liberty
vote do you think he should I don't
think he has to try I think he's been
doing it you've got people who have been
dorste wealth Ron Paul and Rand Paul who
are coming over they've come over to
cruise aside and they said you know what
he stands for liberty and that's why
there is around his side on his feet
so yeah the weight contrast to see
between Rand Paul and Ted Cruz is maybe
foreign policy that'd be about it but
otherwise they're pretty much in line
with return to the Constitution what
place to the libertarians having the GOP
right now do you think they're ascendant
do you think if the libertarian moment
is fading I don't know if it's fading or
ascended necessarily i'd like to think
it's a sin that i consider myself
somewhat libertarian i think that i
think that what what libertarians should
do at this point is look to the field
and see who best advances the message of
liberty and I think that Ted Cruz is
with a natural choice for people who
support a rainfall what do you think
about being relegated to this free
speech zone a mile away from where the
media is assembled well what's the end
of course it's a terrible infringement
and encroachment on free speech but
that's the way it goes here in America
people it's going to be worse under
supreme print up residency let me tell
you thanks so much thank you verify